what are the best ways to build plot
twists I think you just have to find
what's organic to your story
you know I do think you need to surprise
the reader I do try to um
you know sometimes when I think of a
scene
I'll try to think okay this is the way
the scene would go but what if we went
this way instead you know like I haven't
seen that but I also think you need to
be really honest with yourself when
you're doing that like does this work
better like because just because you
haven't seen it doesn't mean it works
you know and I I do I would rather be
effective than
I mean sure it's good I do try to create
new things I do try to go in unexpected
directions but if you're going in a
Direction that's not satisfying
I I think you're sort of uh
you're writing for yourself and not for
your readers at that point you know I
mean as an example I wrote a short story
once about a a guy
who is a werewolf and every time the
full moon comes out he chains himself up
in the basement and he like tranquilizes
himself you know so they won't hurt
anyone and then you know he has this
whole process of how he gets out of it
the next day
and then one day he does all this but
someone is still like mauled you know in
the town he's in and so it's sort of
trying to figure out well how could this
have happened I know I was chained up I
know I did everything and he's like
trying to figure out what's going on
and when you get to the end of the story
you find out there's another werewolf
you know that came to town
and to me I thought that was really cool
but I remember one of my friends read it
and I was like oh you know I was kind of
disappointed because I really was I
wanted to see how he figured out how to
get out you know like I thought that was
going to be the whole thing that like
maybe the wolf side of him is becoming
smarter you know something like that
along those lines and I had never even
thought about that but I it just made me
think that you know
for him he found that story unsatisfying
and I think it's better to satisfy the
reader when you can than just be
different you know just for the sake of
being different
you said you'd rather be effective than
be novel yeah I mean I'd rather the
scene works and that the reader enjoys
it and feels something from it than to
be different just for the sake of being
different you know I mean
you can it's and sometimes it can be
easy to be different in a very cheap way
you know I mean if you if you're writing
a a spy thrower and you get to the end
and the hero just fails you know like
sure that's different but it's probably
not very satisfying to the reader unless
you make that failure you know mean
something or matter or lead to something
else that's interesting but if it's just
like oh you thought this would happen
and instead this happens but there's
it's disconnected from everything else
or it's not satisfying to the reader I
think that that's being novel but you're
not being effective you're not you're
not satisfying the reader you're not
presenting a a compelling story end
every chapter on a cliffhanger or
surprise ending
I I if you can without it being forced I
mean I always try to you know I think
your goal at the end of the chapter is
to make the reader read the next chapter
right so Cliffhanger is a really good
way to do that but it's not the only way
I mean I think even if you've sort of
resolved the drama of that scene you can
sort of
give a hint you know that yeah he got
through this but there's more coming or
things aren't as safe as they seem you
know you just I think you always just
try to leave with a little bit of
I don't know what to call it not really
a cliffhanger per se but just a
a sense of danger kind of like what you
were saying before like that kind of
mood that yeah he survived this but he's
certainly not safe you know there's
there's the story is still moving
would you put like a surprise Revelation
to something that keeps people a little
bit on their edge of their seat but
curious I think actually one of my
editors said what I tend to do and they
they like this like oh I like the way
you end chapters I usually just try to
find something sort of
symbolic in the language that might be a
little Sinister like you know if they've
just gotten through a big red car chase
and it's Sunset you know I might say you
know the sun dripped red blood across
the sky as they vanished into the
horizon or something like that you know
where it's it's not really literally
implying anything but it just gives you
the sort of mood of uh danger you know
and I remember an editor had said oh I
really like the way you end your
visual cues of of something sinister you
know
and how do you start the chapter
varies yeah I mean I just think I think
you want to try to get in late and get
out right at the right time you know I
mean try not to spend too much time with
Exposition I mean you need a little but
I try to do the bare minimum uh and I
just try to
start I mean it sounds kind of
silly to say but I just try to start
where it's most interesting you know I
mean if two people are in an argument
you know I don't necessarily need to see
what led up to that argument I just want
to start with the argument you know if
they're arguing about whether they
should you know send someone into this
territory to get an agent out you know I
don't need to see the girl walk up you
know go in the elevator walk into the
office and sit down for the briefing and
then get into the argument I just want
to start with the argument you know
should we go in and help this guy or not
you know that's the point of the scene
so I think that kind of comes down to
knowing what the point of the chapter is
I mean I do think that every chapter
should have a reason for being there and
when I say chapter it's kind of
interchangeable to me with scene I tend
to write one scene per chapter but not
everybody does so you know each scene
needs to have a reason if the reason is
exposition and sometimes that's
necessary I think you need to make it as
short as possible as quick as possible
like give them what they need to know
and move on
is that something you've perfected over
the years because you know in the
beginning we just want to sit down and
just pour all of this out I don't know
if I'd say I've perfected it I mean I
think I was always aware of it because
like I said I'd written screenplays and
things beforehand and I do think
screenplays kind of teach you to be very
economical you know with your language
because you're so constrained by time
so I don't think I necessarily had a
huge problem with it but I do I will say
that you know writing that first book
I definitely
would be more inclined to add things
because I'm like oh man I don't know if
I can make it to 80 000 words or a
hundred thousand words you know whatever
in my head it was going to be so I'm
like all right I'll talk about this you
know and I would sort of go off on
tangents I I you know I think through
editing most of the excess there was
trimmed back but I don't even then it
wasn't you know massive I mean I think
the difference between the finished
edited book and the original manuscript
was probably like maybe 10 or 12 percent
you know so it wasn't a huge amount but
I do remember that sense of I don't know
if I can write this many words like I
better talk about this and talk about
this you know and and then and then when
you do it you realize oh no it's like I
actually don't have room for all that I
got to get to the point like you know
because and move on how important is
setting up Clues I think it I mean it
certainly depends on what you're writing
if you're writing a mystery it's super
important
um my stories I wouldn't say they're
really Mysteries per se
um
they tend to be more about
kind of this journey that King goes on
in each one you know so it's I don't
think it's like
he's not necessarily trying to find out
you know who killed you know suspect a
or something like that it's more about
you need to go find this guy and kill
him or you need to go find this guy and
get this laptop that he has and I tend
to somehow connect the goal to something
that happened in his past so as he goes
on this Mission he's sort of reflecting
on
something in his past that troubles him
or that you know that he failed or that
is a source of guilt for him so they're
sort of if not directly linked then kind
of metaphorically linked if you're
writing a mystery you know obviously the
clues are really important but I think
in any case whether you're writing a
mystery or even with me with where I've
you know sometimes I have a scenario
where there's a double agent you know
and and you know someone is revealed to
not be who you thought they were and
usually that's planned out but there
have been instances where I've been
writing a scene I thought you know this
would just be so much better if this
person was the traitor you know and the
great thing about writing is you can
always go back and add in seed in those
Clues you know so if that's why I said
like before it's good to divert from
your outline sometimes and surprise
yourself there's nothing stopping you
from going back where you introduce that
character and maybe add in something
that makes them seem a little Shifty or
add in a motive that you know you didn't
have before you know I think people tend
to think of writing uh linearly and for
the most part part you do but there's
nothing stopping you from jumping around
and changing things